good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy hump day
sorry
happy wednesday everyone hope everyone's
having a great day i'm having a great
day because i'm joined by my roses my
husband bensoffer hi
hump day
do you love that commercial there are
just a few commercials that really stick
in your head what's the other ones uh
liberty mutual with the emu liberty
liberty liberty
the don't be wise all take zeizal that's
a good one also idk my bff chill yeah
that's a good one i agree yeah oh of
course you can't flow no progresso no
aggressive no progress is the soup no no
progressives in the soup yes
which one is the insurance company and
which one is the soup progressive
insurance progressive soup but and if in
terms of iconic commercials i don't know
how we're sitting here not talking about
working for an hourly wage i went to
high school didn't do great still i
gotta make my cash um glad we got that
education connection's a good one you
know what and maybe the reason why i
didn't you know have a good college
experience is because i didn't use
education connection it's possible it's
possible it also could be the reason
that you're smart
welcome back to the chose ben how you
doing good i'm really excited you're
here i'm really excited to be here as
well for those confused we did mention
that you would be switching days with
jackie but then we needed to switch it
back we're just juggling a busy life a
new mom and just bear with us so today's
ben he's going to do deer toasters with
me tomorrow is a very special episode um
it's not me it's jackie because i have
to go travel we're heading to austin
tomorrow we're doing a meet and greet at
specs
and we're going to be selling spritz and
having a good time taking pictures
signing stuff so it'll be fun so i can't
do tomorrow's show but jackie's gonna
hold it down with an episode with uh
with someone special
are you telling people or you're not
telling people i don't know i kind of
want to be a drama queen about it okay
yeah but if you do live in austin
thursday night specs it's gonna be lit
it's gonna be lit so join us there and
don't forget to tune in to tomorrow's
episode and yeah i'm so excited to be
here ben there's been so much going on
with you with spritz um i think we
should talk about like the major
milestone that spritz recently achieved
yes uh spritz society is now on united
airlines yes
crazy unbelievable partnership the
people at united are unbelievable and it
is a great airline and nobody's holding
a gun to my head saying no it's true
i've actually um i've been talking about
that journey recently with brian how
i've really become like a united girly
um
it's a premium airline we're on their
routes to italy this summer we're in
some of the lounges it's very exciting
if you need if you're looking for all
the details they're on our instagram if
you want to catch spritz in the wild um
at which lounges and on which routes so
i'm so proud of you ben thank you
darling i'll actually let me just
quickly say that there's only two
uh from may 6 to august 6th if you are a
chicago toaster
you can fly from
chicago o'hare to milan and if you are a
new york toaster from may 6th to august
26th you can fly from newark new jersey
to roma
and and it's available in the lounge in
the lounges right yes it's really it's
just in chicago and newark yeah oh my
god where are we flying out of tomorrow
no we're not we can't see it it's also
not until the 26th in new york it's just
so cool like nobody's on planes like we
got on a plane no it's so crazy i've
been in business for like
eight months and we got on a plane like
it's really cool and the variety pack
yesterday thanks for talking about it
yeah we launched our variety pack it's a
great success so if you're looking for
spritz and you want to try all four
flavors this variety pack has eight cans
two cans
per box and you can try all of them
for fun i actually have a i have a
custom code um
eight pack season
szn eight pack
season s
and so ben have you been 17
how have you been since we last had you
on the toast
when was the last time a couple weeks
couple weeks i've been good you know
just just doing my thing
trying to survive
it's tough in these streets
every day you walk outside you're like
am i gonna get stabbed totally
and every day that you come home not
stabbed is a win is a win and then you
come home to me which is just like for
you so special it is um and you come
home to theo and the beautiful home i've
made for us so it's so special it must
be so nice to be home is amazing thank
you yes i love the home you do yes and
isn't it amazing when your butler
returns
i left yesterday i want you guys to know
oh my gosh i want you guys to know do
not do this seriously because you're
wrong i want you guys to know don't do
it theo has walked at 2pm
i went out to play monopoly at seven i
said i'll be back at nine i'll walk him
when we get back just hang on monopoly
ran over as monopoly always does you are
literally like leaving out such
important facts ready okay
ben says can i play monopoly with my
friends ben is in this like losery ass
monopoly league like you'll
they made their own rules they have like
a google doc it is loser central okay
now the google doc was covered you're
literally living in like nine years ago
did you not make up your own roles no
they're great i said yesterday like why
don't you invite this person to come
play with your monopoly's like no he
doesn't know the rules like it's
illusory it's a different it's a way to
make monopoly more real
sure
so he was going out at seven and when
when he goes play monopoly i know it's
like a four or five hour thing so he
always has to like you know
ask nicely because it's a tuesday night
we should be together and because i have
no control over my own life or schedule
somebody said can i play monopoly and i
said yes you can but you have to make
these returns at zara for me along the
way that way i'm getting something out
of this and you have to walk theo so
then you were like oh i'm running late
like i no you threw in theo literally at
the last minute and i said look
just it's fine i'll be home in two hours
but when i wasn't home for four hours
you couldn't just walk him i got into
the kitchen the water bowl was bare not
a drop of water i reject that as well
there wasn't a drop of water because
theo while he was under my care drank
all of the water he was drinking water
don't don't don't how do you know he
drank the water i watched him you're the
camera from the bed i watched him
because i went to go find him he was
sitting on the laundry and then he went
up to get water and i escorted him there
but you literally said it's totally fine
i'll walk him when i get home so okay i
was just listening to you it's totally
fine i'll walk him when i get one time i
was timing you okay by the way theo is
totally fine
he's a bladder king i think it's really
your fault no i don't think so
and you lost monopoly so it like wasn't
even worth it was such a good game too
oh
went really deep the problem is i
invested all my money in the browns
what are the browns
uh mediterranean and baltic they're
secretly those are purple what did i say
brown it depends on the board that you
have we play on a more premium board and
they're brown i have to say purple is an
old game i don't i don't know exactly
your rules but in a historic game of
monopoly that i once played i owned
those cheap ones at the front i had
hotels on
all of them because it's so cheap and i
[ __ ] won because
every time and people dismiss it because
it's like 60 correct every time i
somebody landed on that i was getting
like a thousand bucks because it cost me
like three hundred dollars to put a
hotel on it correct you actually get 450
for baltic and 200 for mediterranean 250
with hotels and yes
cheap builds
big hits no one's ever out of cash
because they just passed go so even if
they're on their way out great property
next would be the blues but yet people
really overrate the side of the board
i don't think the blues are valuable the
thing is people get sent to jail so many
times
that the ones between jail and free
parking the purples and the orange the
pinks and the oranges are the most high
traffic zones
because people are always being sent to
jail and then getting out are you
implying that you want to join the
league no no you feel quite strategic no
honestly that's a part that's the whole
part of the league we take monopoly
seriously monopoly is fun every once in
a while and you have to be playing with
fun people
i'll tell you why this version is fun
this version is fun because there's no
luck every time you land on a property
goes up for auction that is why jackie
hates monopoly like it's a game of luck
this game is not of luck at all it's 100
of skill it's fantastic i'm so happy wow
should we play i'm sorry that you found
something that you're passionate about
yeah it's a great game
there was a time where we were playing
oof all the time right and kobe been
like you couldn't really do anything but
now it's like i don't know no it's
sparse because life is back to normal
sparse
um well i'm so happy for you it's so
important to have hobbies yeah and if
you go on hasbro.com
monopoly
isn't that what they do hasbro hasbro
hasbro hasbro hasbro
hasbro yeah not hasbro
has bro hasbro
you're saying it wrong again okay
hasbro okay it's has bro like you're
adding like an ough hasbro
hasbro hasbro
i think you're wrong
am i is he saying it weird
hasbro hasbro
no you're saying it wrong hasbro
okay shoot me
okay if you go on hasbro.com
no i was making a terrible joke that you
could use code toast but you didn't even
pick up oh good do you think i was
sending them to the the manual for
monopoly i thought that like you were
gonna show them like a way to make your
own rules or something oh god i'm not
that big of a loser
no i think actually maybe i am i think
it's really sweet you know darling some
guys get together you know they do drugs
they gamble not you no you're playing
monopoly you guys even drink no of
course not sober
i love it yeah i love that yeah it's
good
it flexes the mind i personally i don't
know why like everything you like to do
without me takes five hours like if you
like i don't mind you playing golf but
it's eight hours monopoly is four hours
i know you think it's two hours it's
never two hours it's always four so like
the fact that everything you like to do
without me takes so long like that hurts
my feelings i'm sorry
it just means that they're good games as
opposed to like short games like sorry
i'm not playing checkers on the street
that would be fun too
that also could take four hours yeah
depending if you get a really good
opponent on the game
um well ben's gonna join me here today
for the fast five stories and he's also
gonna do dear toasters with us because
nobody gives advice quite like ben's
offer no no i would agree yeah i give
great advice yeah i also don't ever get
like two on one side or the other i'm
very even keeled mm-hmm
i can see somebody get hit by a bus
right in front of me straight face oh
please and then christ
do you remember that time somebody once
pulled a knife in duane raid
that was terrifying yeah i would say
that if it happened to me i would be
straight-faced okay because like i was
pretty calm and you were like
we should leave by the way you were like
let's stay no i wasn't what there's
somebody with a knife first of all we
were online for a long time we were
finally at the front i was not giving up
my spot in line why why wouldn't you
give up your spot
second of all if us leaving like draws
attention to us he was standing by the
door so we should get closer to the man
with a knife
no we should leave the store in order to
leave the store we have to get closer to
him he was standing right by the sliding
door
i don't know and we got to check out and
everything was fine when you hear that
look closer what do you think
closer
so baby pull me closer no but this is
like our game well yeah no i'm thinking
neo
closer i don't even know that song but
me and ben have started to play this
game before bed let's play it right now
okay yeah i'll start
so
so
pull me closer
so
i don't know sing us a song of the piano
is just like it doesn't even relate you
do what's impossible it's it's word
association by the way yeah you sing the
first word of a song the other person
has to guess it
love
do it again
love
oh wait i did it wrong
[Laughter]
oh let me guess is for the way you look
at me
that was [ __ ] hilarious and a great
place to dive into the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
oh [ __ ] i forgot
never [ __ ] today's episode is brought to
you by peloton pelo thomas peloton has a
team of world-class instructors ready to
motivate you 24 7. their instructors are
highly trained fitness pros who motivate
you through every workout whether you're
a regular at the gym or someone who's
new and getting back into working out
whatever your fitness level is pelton's
instructors don't just teach they
motivate
and the best part about peloton is that
they fit seamlessly into your life so if
you don't feel recently like you know
motivated to get up motivation is
definitely something i struggle with if
you don't feel like
you're easily motivated peloton has just
the thing for you there's something for
everyone whether you're looking for a
10-minute upper body stretch between
calls or a 40-minute run before bed
peloton works with your schedule whether
you have five minutes or an hour
plus you'll never have an awkward
encounter in the locker room again
gym locker rooms are really just
a special place in hell oh yeah um and
peloton is all done from the safety of
your own home they have amazing amazing
music selections for a lot of their
classes they have so many amazing um
instructors who are like famous now it's
so crazy jackie's obsessed with her
peloton she has the bike before during
after pregnancy she was using it all and
it really helped her mental health
obviously her physical health and she's
a huge fan of the peloton and you can
follow her at jackie ow she wants wanted
me to promote that right now is the
perfect time to try out peloton the
peloton bike plus is now 500 less it is
the best price yet including free
delivery and setup and there are more
game changing prices available on the
original peloton bike and the peloton
tread visit onepeleton.com to learn more
onepeleton.com
to learn more what's it like in a
women's locker room um breasts
everywhere
it's it's awkward like
what's it like in a men's locker room so
much saggy balls just like old men just
like walking around with like their nuts
clanking against their ankles yeah like
it's just so and like it's funny when i
was younger i used to think like how in
the world
how in the world are people just walking
around naked
and now i understand the older you get
you don't give a [ __ ] because i'm never
going to see this person again why am i
inconveniencing myself in the fear of
them seeing my balls when in reality
it doesn't matter i'm never seeing them
again yeah but like you are a public
figure no i'm not doing that i'm just
saying from their perspective you know
do i frequent gym locker rooms i've been
to a gym in years spa locker rooms
for one
spas
are typically empty in the locker room
two i love a robe
yeah i'm
i remember the first time i was in like
a it wasn't a locker room but it was
like a communal dressing room at a
department store and like that's where i
first saw like boobs and like a bush and
i was like what the [ __ ] is this
bush it was bush it was the 90s man
actually it wasn't the 90s the early
2000s
um all right ready for the past five
yeah first up you know kim kardashian is
getting backlash again for something
moronic fans are slamming controlling
kim kardashian for telling pete davidson
to remove his hat pete davidson's fans
have taken issue with kim kardashian
telling him to remove a hat while
shooting behind the scenes footage of
their time prepping for the met gala in
a clip kim uploaded an in a clip
uploaded to the kardashian social
instagram page kim is telling the snl
star to take the double hats off as he
wore a purple cap over a navy one
um
while filming
he said i don't know where to put my hat
and then kim said she points to her
assistant she'll hold it just in case
because if it works and we want to use
this somewhere just if i want to post
any behind the scenes content so it's
like
it's so dumb like they're holding hands
and like she's trying on the marilyn
monroe dress he's wearing a baseball cap
and then a baseball cap on top of it and
she's like wait take the hat off cause
like in case this is cute like i don't
want you to look stupid um and he was
like oh you don't want me to have a
double hat i appreciate that thank you
and she's like no i'm just looking out
for you it's such a
um
irrelevant clip there's like nothing
there and fans are like she's
controlling
now as someone who frequently gets
controlled how does this make you feel
it's like a really stupid story right
like by the way today it's bleak no i no
just like
why are people upset why are people
talking about this why is this news
because people have literally no lives
but from the perspective of myself
uh yes as one that is controlled
i would never even dare a double hat i
get controlled on my t-shirt or my
button i don't really feel like i
control your t-shirts like if you're
wearing something with a hole like i'm
doing you a favor no it's not a hole
you'll just say like oh yeah you can
leave the house if you want to look ugly
okay that's the thing okay oh yeah i
support what you're wearing
hideous beast
ben always comes like do you like this
outfit i'm like no you asked for my
opinion i say no why i need to explain
to you i just don't like it so then cuz
you have no taste yeah okay bozo
whatever you say
anytime i put on even a drop of color if
i'm not wearing black i wear a light
shade of pink bozo it's not a light
shade of pink okay you're wearing a nice
pink shirt you gotta wear yellow pants
and a cowboy hat like you're always
taking it to the next level so you ask
my opinion if you didn't ask i wouldn't
say anything you say do you like what
i'm wearing no you look like bozo
so the thing is i've said i want you to
stop asking my opinion because you don't
like my opinion it's true
because your opinion is wrong right okay
so stop asking okay bozo see you
enjoy okay you work at a party this
afternoon
this is like a big nothing burger from
kim and pete like they're totally fine
let's stop reading into everything and
like if kim
like kim approved this video going out
so like if she thought it was bad she
wouldn't post it you know totally it's
fine it's fine there's nothing there
um but it was a really bleak day for
stories so sorry about that um next up
is a hollywood reporter story so
story
take me out which is a broadway show the
theater is pursuing takedown requests
they're going to add additional staff
after the nude photo of jesse williams
has circulated so they said it is deeply
unfortunate that one audience member
chose to disrespect the production their
fellow audience members and most
importantly the cast in this manner so
let me give you the back story
there is a broadway show going on now
called take me out and jesse williams
who's an actor from um
grey's anatomy isn't it and he has like
a full frontal noodle scene like a penis
and everything and somebody snapped a
photo of it and it's gone absolutely
viral because allegedly his penis is
quite large um and all the fanfare has
been you know very uh
what's the word i'm looking for
has been in his favor it's all been very
complementary but it's still like an
enormous invasion of privacy and
like you're really not supposed to film
anything at a broadway show let alone
someone being completely naked so now
like the theater and the production
company has spoken out they're gonna be
adding all these different levels of
security and um
they really should have a no phone
policy yeah but
you're nude in front of an audience yeah
but it's in front of an audience it's a
controlled environment yeah but it's
gonna happen anyways i don't think so
like if people had a modicum of respect
i don't think it would interesting and i
did see like reactions from jesse
williams like he doesn't really seem to
care yeah because he's full frontally
nude in front of people every day yeah
but like still that's not
that doesn't make it an excuse i'd just
like to know if he's upset or if
somebody else is upset for him honestly
i'm a little upset like i think it's a
huge invasion of privacy and like
imagine do you think it's imagine if it
was a woman do you think it's a huge
invasion of privacy even if it's a woman
if they don't care
no that's a good call because like jesse
williams doesn't seem to be bothered but
like i just think on principle like it's
[ __ ] up on principle this is the exact
problem we have people care too much
about other people who don't care
no i i i still think it's wrong sorry
why it's not you
i'm just allowed to have an opinion
that's literally what the show is for no
i get it but like if you were nude on
broadway and they did it you can be
upset but no for sure
i just think conceptually it ain't right
okay
i think it's not a movie that's getting
played everywhere it's a controlled
environment like you have to buy tickets
there's something a little a little
weird about it
i think that it's definitely a
[ __ ] up move by the person who did it
yeah but if he is unbothered i think
he's probably happy with the press
because i've never heard of mr williams
well he's a really big actor so that's
on you okay well
he's on like the number one show of all
time great and i mentioned that he has
apparently quite the hog according to
social media yeah people are quaking and
do you think that's like joey tribiani
where he took
what did he take to to put on to make
his penis look was it circumference
it was like baloney low for whatever
yeah yes um
do you think it's his real penis or you
think it's like a clay mold the thing is
like we really don't know
who to trust anymore because do you
remember when i made you watch that one
scene
horrible in sex life oh my god um that
big penis scene i made men watch it for
my tea talk um that turned out to be a
prosthetic
shocking
so
yes that's totally a thing but that's
also movie magic i don't know if you can
really get away with a prosthetic on
stage in real life you know something
yeah but that's a good question i think
it was real crazy yeah
cool yeah i did see it sorry i don't
know why i'm lying was it big um yeah i
searched it on twitter because i was
just like what's everyone talking about
um
it was it was enormous yeah
really big
not as big as yours
it's not all about size it's about love
girth
it's all about love i agree i totally
agree i love you i love you too um so
yes i did see it i don't know why i was
lying i was just ashamed of my actions
like but you know
i'm a part of the problem i am 100 and i
own that and i really i apologize it's
okay but yes i agree with your sentiment
as long as jesse williams isn't bothered
than like nobody else should be yeah is
this fun you're having microphone
trouble just like push that down oh and
pull it towards you yeah i didn't see
that the thing the little mushroom cap
was popping up yeah no i remember my
first podcast
[Music]
you remember my first podcast
oh man you're being funny today
yeah
it's about love yeah i am
so um where did we land on the story
we landed that people need to stop
getting upset for other people by the
way i don't think there's like a
you're upset no there's not like he's
not upset there's not a wave of backlash
i just want to let you know i just like
had a weird feeling about it stop
touching your microphone no it's good
just stop touching it you're making
sounds and torturing the podcasters it's
good now just put it up close here and
then literally just adjust it i'm just
trying to show you okay just no more
touching get fun you good yeah you know
more attention so i just wanted to say i
don't think there's like a big backlash
movement i personally was just like
we're all quaking over this moment and
it is an invasion of privacy that's all
i was saying i understand
there isn't backlash but the the theater
doesn't want this to happen again
because
because they want people to pay tickets
yeah
they won't be able to get it for free
you know i hate broadway shows but i
just might have to see this one yeah
it's their click bait totally i wonder
if it helps ticket sales of course it
does for sure this hurt their paywall
now nobody's gonna go see it right it's
like doing something on patreon into the
real world exactly
well um
i guess i'll just have to see the play
and let everyone know if i think it's a
prosthetic you can so um that's what i
do for
for the job that i love
you'll see a show
give you a million dollars you won't go
to that show hate broadway shows like i
hate broadway shows um okay next up is a
little movie news from the hollywood
reporter avatar the new way of water
the teaser has dropped the trailer and
it has gotten 150 million views on its
first day out
so james cameron's long-awaited sequel
launched online monday after debuting
exclusively and oh
you ever see avatar yeah of course i
didn't really dark story um i feel like
it's something i would really like when
i was in the 12th grade we took a trip
to poland to visit like all the
concentration camps and that morning of
our flight it was delayed so we were all
like at our high school like ready to
get on the bus but we didn't like have
to go because it was delayed like six
hours so they just like said come back
so i went to see avatar oh nice yeah um
theaters
in theaters yeah oh wow so the first
teaser trailer for james cameron's
sequel avatar the way the way of water
wrote a huge wave of interest when
debuting online early monday after
playing exclusively in cinemas over the
weekend the teaser finished its first 24
hour online window with 149 million
views including 23 million from china
according to disney in 20th century
that's ahead of the star wars films rise
of like luke skywalker like it's
breaking all these records the teaser
trailer
for um that played exclusively in
theaters first i didn't realize that oh
you mean like the the premieres before
the trailers before the movies
that's what they're saying
the movie named premiere but like you
know when you go to see a movie and then
they have the trailers
so that people like went to go see it
and then online it got 150 million views
you okay i'm confused what do you think
it's about
it's got 150 million views yeah and what
do you mean like what about the trailer
the trailer
the trailer got 150 million views great
and
it's now playing before movies like the
commercials the previews oh okay
yeah
i got it okay okay is there more to get
no
okay now the question is like how long
is too long to drop a sequel because i
saw that movie in 2012 i was in the 12th
grade yeah so it's 10 years
do we care
yeah the only reason we care is because
the movie market is so bad right maybe
this is the thing to bring it back to
life there haven't been nobody's cared
about movies in quite some time that's
actually not true the most recent
spider-man broke like every single
record and
i'm sorry i'm just saying no i mean as a
spider-man fan i don't see spider-man's
without tobey maguire well then you're
not a spider-man fan because there's
been like four movies since then that's
my spider-man yeah for sure toby nothing
but respect for my spider-man
um however you could not lit i saw the
movie i think i actually even saw it
twice you couldn't pay me if you had a
gun to my head you say tell me what
avatar's about i couldn't tell you
it's about these little blue people
who live in a fake universe but then
there's also people in the real world
it's been too long honestly i'm curious
if like it'll be
as big or bigger than the original
i'll see it there's i got to see the
first one you really want the first
three hours three and a half it's so
long and i saw it in imax i had like a
migraine
i know i always hated an imax because
you can't possibly look at the whole
screen i'm not into 3d movies like it's
fun i hate 3d it's fun for a second
but not fun at all hurts your head it
hurts your head yeah i have to bring
like advil and excitement glasses are
the problem the glasses yeah they need
to find a way to do 3d without glasses
100 can't they just instead of like
putting the thing in front of your eye
just put a screen in front of the entire
screen so the entire thing to the entire
audience looks like 3d it's an amazing
call
why do i have to put it here just put it
there it's 100 great call
great call i'm a genius you're a genius
wow um so
yeah people are excited about it i guess
and i'm curious to see if it like you
know helps revive the movie industry the
theater industry but i just feel like at
some point it's like
who cares it's so late
yeah
but maybe i don't know i mean i guess
when you have to just like flip these
quick sequels it's also like
shitty they didn't spend any time on
that's true
they've been refining this script
this cast
locations
it should be a great movie if it takes
you 10 years it better be a great movie
and it's james cameron
did the titanic no but also like now
that i think about it
the way that like we keep talking about
how there's allegedly illegally blonde
three in the making
yeah like mindy kaling is writing it
should be really good um
i don't know like there's very few
details coming out about it i do believe
reese is in it and like i am excited
about that jennifer coolidge yeah so
it's been 10 years same way that i'm
excited about that i guess someone
really could be excited about
this i just want to share if reece
witherspoon and jennifer coolidge aren't
in that movie boycott what is your um
favorite legally blonde movie the first
or the second
oh
because they're both really good
ah
the first overall is
definitely a better movie
but bruiser's bill i know it hits home
don't animal test don't test on animals
and
just fight for what you believe in 100
it's a beautiful message she took her
are you crying yeah you're choking up no
are you yes
she took her law degree and put it to
work for those that mattered most to her
for those who couldn't speak people had
no voice the people who couldn't speak
for themselves it's really beautiful it
is bruiser's bill
and what's her name for mrs dalfire's
such a [ __ ] sally field yeah yeah she
was like she's a great actress but that
does she have any endearing roles
she's um forrest gump's mom
was she nice and foreign i think so i
don't even remember that movie i've seen
it but beautiful film yeah beautiful
film
cool getting choked up so um congrats to
everyone who's excited to see avatar
that's exciting for them yes congrats to
you and we'd love to see it um we have
two more stories and they are brought to
you by stamps.com if you've got a small
business inflation isn't doing you any
favors right now it's harder than ever
to stay profitable so if you're looking
for a way to cut costs mailing and
shipping
shipping is a great place to start
simply use stamps.com to mail and ship
and get access to exclusive discounts
great rates on shipping from usps and
ups it's an easy way to keep more money
in your pocket stamps.com saves you time
money and stress for more than 20 years
they've been an indispensable asset for
over 1 million businesses no matter what
business you're in stamps.com can help
you save on shipping whether you're at
office sending out invoices in etsy shop
sending out products or a warehouse
shipping out trucks truckloads of orders
stamps.com is the mailing and shipping
solution for you if you sell for
multiple stores no problem stamps.com
seamlessly works with shopify amazon
etsy ebay and more all you need is your
regular computer and printer no special
supplies or equipment required you'll be
up and running in minutes printing any
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send start mailing
and shipping with stamps.com and keep
more money in your pocket every day sign
up with promo code toast for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
there's no no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter toast
okay ready for a little
nightlife
snub news sure anna wintour appears
shocked when asked to show her id
outside a public event so his video has
gone viral
anna wintour appeared momentarily
stunned when she was asked to show id at
an off-broadway show in new york city
monday night
upon arrival at the cherry lane theatre
vogue's editor-in-chief who was rocking
her signature pair of sunglasses had to
present proof of vaccination in order to
enter the venue while anna wintour 72
had no problem showing her vaccine card
a health compliance worker then asked
for a photo id a protocol for all
attendees the devil wears prada
inspiration who was only carrying her
phone at the time was seemingly
flammoxed flummoxed by the request as
seen in footage captured by page six
the video's so awkward the video shows a
publicist quickly jumping in to let the
healthcare worker know that it was fine
and that this legendary editor could be
let in without proof of identification
wintor then made her way into the
theater for opening night of allison
lieby's oh god a show about abortion she
attended the one woman show with her 34
year old daughter and a rep for vogue
did not respond to page six's requests
for comment so in the video she's the
woman was too stunned to speak quickly
i
am sure that show is amazing what's
worse than a one-woman show
no i agree i'm sorry by the way we know
nothing about it but i agree like one
i'm sure that show is awesome yeah one
women's show is in general did you feel
that way about a one-man show yes okay
horrible no i think i think i have a
stigma about one woman shows from that
one episode of friends me too chapter
one
my first period
um agreed i think one woman chose except
for excuse me my one woman show no
that's not a one-woman show that's not
the same thing
one is comedy and one is not like other
girls yeah that's a good show
wow i just caught you
do you think my show was terrible it's
not a one-woman show it is
it's
um okay so what do you think about anna
wintour not walking around without an
identification i think that
it's
god i which way should i play this i
don't know i can decide i can fight both
if this was the debate team i could
argue both sides i mean like how the
[ __ ] do you think you are bring your
[ __ ] id with you but also like you
don't know whose [ __ ] is no so i'm
gonna fight the side of
who do you think you are okay
because i guess i'll just take the other
side in this climate
people's jobs there's literally
somebody's who somebody whose job it is
to make sure that a vaccine card matches
an id
it's terrible inconvenience it's
terrible that every single person must
endure it's terrible
but you have to and it's pretty odd to
me
for anna wintour to assume
that the person that checks ids at the
theater knows who she is totally i would
say that 90 and again this is just
hollywood elite thinking yes everyone
knows their [ __ ] don't stink and
everyone knows who they are i bet you 95
of the world if they looked anna wintour
in the face would say who the [ __ ] is
this woman that's actually a really good
call i wasn't sure where i wanted to
land on this but you've actually
convinced me because yes anna wintour is
definitely someone you know like if
you're
heavily invested in like fashion and pop
culture and that's not everyone so like
she's not you know kim kardashian like
not everyone knows your face she's not
dolly pardon like beyonce like she's
definitely a niche celebrity yeah and i
would argue she's much more of a
socialite than she is a celebrity so the
fact like the idea that someone you know
checking ids doesn't know who she is is
not the craziest thing in the world um
and i think you know you're right i
think like the level of entitlement be
like
to not walk around with an id when if
you live in new york for the last year
you have to walk around everywhere with
your id
and your vax card it is literally the
most annoying thing ever people i know
started taking a picture of their vax
card and their id together and then
making it the background of their phone
just so that when they would walk in
places they could flip their phone like
it's so inconvenient everyone knows that
everyone knows that yeah so like what
are you doing leaving your house without
your id no it's just weird and then also
like the end of the story like oh the
publicist swooped in to save the day
it's like why does the publicist have
any power over this guy checking ids
right not only rules are rules rules are
rules whether you agree with them or not
it's a rule
it's a terrible rule no like literally
like you are still having to wear masks
in a broadway play and that's literally
why i won't go it's also just like so
different like it's like a public health
rule
it's not like uh oh like let's get this
kid in underage he's a celebrity right
like that's a him problem yeah but the
reason why these things still exist is
because broadway
like needs to make sure that
broadway is still doing like the most
even though new york has dropped i
literally just sat down planes have
dropped no no one wears masks anymore
right except for broadway i went into a
broadway show i had to wear my mask the
entire time
i did of course sneak it down a little
bit during and then the lights went up
and there's this woman with a
another she's employed to do this not
her fault no oh actually no sorry
volunteer her fault
holding holding a big [ __ ] sign
mascot
mask up it's like my my mask and
everyone's masks were down for the hour
and 30 minutes that the lights were off
right of course for the 15 minutes that
the lights are on
mask up that's [ __ ] funny volunteer
sorry the only thing worse than a
one-woman show is a volunteer
volunteers why because volunteers it's
and i'm not talking about a volunteer
that like volunteers at the
moment or oh
volunteers are amazing like volunteers
go out vol exactly volunteers at the
botanical gardens are amazing what the
botanical gardens what about soup
kitchens
kitchens shelters all these are
wonderful volunteers what volunteers are
you talking about the volunteer who
wants to say mascot
at the broadway show just that one no
there are a lot of volunteers like that
okay
and i'll think of more
i don't know if you're right about this
call but i am okay one woman joe
volunteers no listen volunteers are
selfless people by nature they don't get
paid
yeah and some of them take it too far
i agree i do think sometimes uh becoming
a volunteer will give you a power trip
for sure okay what about the volunteers
for the safety patrol those the the
people in in their towns yeah yeah stop
speeding citizens arrests and [ __ ] like
that yeah no volunteers yeah but they're
trying to better the neighborhood they
are because they're bored no how do you
better the neighborhood from home no i i
do think that like those volunteers that
you're talking about like they come from
a good place but they no matter what
like they will end up on some sort of
power trip they're terrible they're not
terrible man they're trying to save
lives and you should slow down you're
always [ __ ] speeding they're talking
to you
very interesting you want to tell them
about the time that you
scratched your car
i've never scratched your car remember
long beach yeah okay 2012 yeah i
remember um i never said i was a good
driver
like
i literally be the first to tell you
like i'm not a good driver and i just
like i can't be bothered to like look
both ways like it's exhausting
i have a question but you you are a good
driver but like you will die on the hill
that you're an amazing driver like
you're actually pretty reckless
one woman show
volunteers
traffic cops
traffic cops are
a special breed of [ __ ] and like i feel
bad for them in the sense that it's like
not their fault because like they're
given routes but like you'll find a
traffic cop on the least busy street in
the world making traffic and then on an
incredibly busy street like 34th street
there won't be a traffic cop in sight
like i'll never understand that i also
no longer like one i don't feel bad
they're getting paid hourly two
my life changed when i realized they had
no power you thought you were thinking
oh
oh you're telling me not to make a left
[ __ ] you i make a left right in front of
them what are they going to do they have
no ticket booklets yeah they can't give
you a take care give me a ticket um i
don't think you should be flipping
people off
but [ __ ] you
volunteer by the way you know it's so
funny they're not volunteers first of
all they're paid city employees and too
like you talk such a big game you've
literally never flipped anyone off and
when we're in the car and i want to
start yelling at people you are
literally the always one holding me back
you're like claudia you don't start a
fight like let's just go totally
so you're big you're talking a big game
you're a big strong man no i'm just
saying you never do that i'm just saying
you literally everything you're saying
right now you're incredibly respectful
to volunteers no you don't start fights
no by the way [ __ ] the volunteers agreed
but like you
[ __ ] the volunteers what are you talking
about not sure
what are you talking about that's true
okay
um can i go to the next turn you can but
i'm also realizing now a pattern which
is so there's a man yelling at us in the
car
and you want to yell back at him the
same way that you wanted to stay when
there was a guy with a knife and dwayne
reed you want to wait for problems yes
no i thrive on adrenaline and violence
for sure
do the toasters know the story of the
bank robbery of course i tell it all the
time jackie actually told me i i can't
say it anymore because i say it all the
time okay well she wanted to stay yeah
of course i fled i want nothing to do
with that paperwork all you had to do
was stay
ready we can move on little human
interest story to wrap up the day
a passenger with no idea how to fly an
airplane lands safely after the pilot
gets sick volunteer
would you say
it's a good kind of volunteer great
volunteer a passenger with no flying
experience successfully landed a small
plane in florida tuesday afternoon after
his pilot suffered a medical emergency
the incredible aviation accomplishment
happened at palm beach international
airport with the help of air traffic
controllers
so he said i've got a serious situation
here the cessna caravan passenger was
reportedly heard telling air traffic
control about 70 miles north of his
final destination my pilot has gone
incoherent i have no idea how to fly a
plane
the dispatcher said roger what's your
position
i have no idea the passenger reportedly
said i can see the coast of florida in
front of me and i have no
idea dispatch said maintain wings level
and just try to follow the coast either
north or southbound were trying to
locate you
controllers helped the plane descend and
finally located at about 25 miles north
of palm beach in boca raton
from there air traffic control
coached the man down to the ground in
what is considered a safe and steady
landing the station reported
the controller said you just witnessed a
couple passengers land a plane he said
over the radio and the other radio guy
was like did you just say the passengers
landed the plane that's correct oh my
gosh great job
wow
that's amazing that's an amazing story
that's like literally my worst [ __ ]
nightmare good for them i could barely
drive a car yeah good for them
by the way it's funny
you think you can't fly a plane i bet
you could
it's very frightening
there are a lot of people that can fly
planes someone's coaching me over even
though like when the guy said i'm
literally a passenger i have no idea how
to fly a plane then the air traffic
control says maintain wings level and
follow the coast normal people what the
[ __ ] does that mean well maintain wings
level would be just like don't go down
or up
maintain wings level i guess
and the coast you're looking at it stay
on the coast i just feel like he could
have been more like layman's terms yeah
for sure but his job is the
anti-layman's i would literally just be
like tell me what buttons to press yeah
i would start facetiming them so they
could see what was going on the part of
the story that i don't understand
i wouldn't even know
how to get in contact with air traffic
patrol they're always on they're always
on like that headset oh they're always
on oh it's on i think so you don't think
it's like a button you need to press to
get them i follow this girl on tick tock
who's like a pilot she has like this
really cute tiny plane she's always
flying like one to two slides yeah she's
like charlie
air traffic to charlie like whatever and
it seems like they're always available
by the way that girl seems to fly like
50 miles at a time it's a really small
plane so she can't like fly cross
country but you can fly like you know
illinois to milwaukee you know yeah yeah
i like her i learned a lot yeah i know
that girl yeah cool 21 charlie that's
always what you say
twitter and charlie to
lift you off
um so okay let's say you're in an
emergency like
are you volunteering let's say there's
like 10 people on a plane they need
someone
of sound mind to get in the seat and
replace the pilot and talk to aircraft
traffic control are you
volunteering
is there nobody else's volunteering no
like or just i don't know but are you
volunteering
i will volunteer if there isn't somebody
like if there's a doctor on board i'm
trusting him a surgeon great hands yeah
that's true
like do i think i could do it sure do i
think that there are probably people on
board that could do it better than me i
would at least like to check yeah i
don't think i'm volunteering i think i
would be a great person to decide
who would be best at landing the plane
i'd love that we could start a coalition
isn't that good yeah like we'll we'll
unionize and i will tell you what's best
for you i love that idea
that is such a crazy story and honestly
like makes me never want to fly
it's just problems always happen in
small planes that's just the truth no
but you know what you always hear about
the accidents are never with these large
planes in time except that flight in
times in malaysia
in times
of
very good
very good
okay we're going to move on to gear
coasters
which is brought to you
by the luminesce breeze cordless
airbrush makeup we don't have a ton of
time to get ready in the morning so
we're always looking for a way to put on
makeup faster and easier and we also
don't like looking cakey or having heavy
makeup we want something that covers up
but that
leaves our skin looking great and that's
why you've got to check out the luminous
and their new breeze cordless airbrush
makeup the breeze is a completely
touchless way to put on foundation and
it's so easy to use no sponges brushes
or fingers that you need to keep clean
with luminesce you get three times more
coverage and you use ten times less
makeup it's designed to work with all
skin type skin tones and their
water-based foundation quickly and
easily covers fine lines and wrinkles so
you can bring it wherever you need plus
it features a no mess tip that prevents
it from spraying in your hair or eyes
luminesce is available in 18 shades
they've got a color for every skin type
and it will replace the shade for free
if it doesn't match
um
if you are looking for a new way to do
your makeup you don't want to like look
cakey or dry the luminesce breeze
cordless makeup is a fabulous solution
the color match on the foundations is
really good i found my match really
easily online but if you don't they also
can help you switch it out really easily
we've been looking for makeup that
doesn't look heavy or cakey on our face
and we finally found it with luminess
breeze airbrush we're thrilled with the
product we're super happy we found it
and we'll probably never go back to
traditional makeup again whether you're
heading back to the office and updating
your beauty routine or you're just
looking for a better faster way to put
on foundation we've got great news right
now if you go to breezetoday.com
toast put in promo code toast you'll
receive 50 off their airbrush makeup
system plus free shipping and because
you're a listener there's a special free
eyeliner valued at over twenty dollars
included just for you
that's fifty percent off plus free
shipping when you go to breezetoday.com
toast put in promo code toast don't
forget you get 30 days to try out
luminesce breeze and if you don't love
it send it back for a full refund
are you ready for tear toasters your
favorite segment sure yep where we give
advice to people who need it if you ever
want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com try and keep it brief but give
us all the you know information we need
ready
hello claudia and ben love you guys but
i need help my roommates and i are
splitting up after two years together
and i noticed that one of them was
posting furniture we all purchased
together on facebook marketplace should
i say something none of us have really
spoken to each other for the last six
months because we went from friends to
enemies after about a year of living
together i'm just not sure it's worth
ending the silence over for less than a
hundred bucks sincerely a broke but
bitter toaster that is so weird like
on principle like i'm a principled
person so i'm like i paid for this
furniture i'm not necessarily agreeing
to sell it on facebook marketplace and
even if i am uh i want my money
but that's a conversation that you have
the day you part ways but they hate the
no not the day you need to prepare no if
you leave an apartment it sounds like
they haven't left yet oh they all live
there together no it says we are
splitting up after two years together
like they're not minutes after six
months keep reading
they haven't spoken to each other for
the last six months but they still live
together that was the bye bye if you
live together and somebody put it on
facebook marketplace very odd yeah like
they they're they're living together and
they currently hate each other and
they're almost out and one of the girls
started selling all their [ __ ] very
weird because i was going to say
cardinal rule if you leave the apartment
if you leave a dresser in the apartment
it's not your dresser anymore yeah once
you leave [ __ ] behind it it's the
apartment stressor unless you say like
i'm leaving this here once i can find
space for it like i want it back great
so then do you pay a storage fee
no
once you leave it it's the apartment but
do you think it's worth her actually
saying something it's like 100 bucks and
they all split it three ways it's three
dollars yes she said she wants the money
but like she doesn't want to end the
silence yes she lives in the apartment
she paid for the thing this girl can't
sell it
maybe the girl what kind of furniture is
it i don't know but maybe the girl is
selling it with the intentions of
splitting up the money
i don't know i think you should say
something just say like hey you noticed
this was on facebook marketplace like is
this really i think we could have gotten
a little more money is this ours
question mark no not ours like maybe she
thinks you don't know and you don't care
that like she can just pocket the money
so you have to let her know i'm on to
you [ __ ] i agree nicely i see you
nicely we see each other yeah nicely
nicely definitely say something next up
love you guys so much i went to end log
in detroit and i love the show i'm ready
because i've been dating my boyfriend
maverick for six years now i moved to
the states to be closer to him and i
absolutely love and adore him the issue
is he has super religious parents that
really control him the other issue is
that when we first started dating i sent
him nudes on snapchat and he
screenshotted them and it synced with
his family's ipad via icloud and long
story short his dad saw my full
breastuses
we were mortified for reference his dad
is practicing muslim and his dad is a
southern his mom is a southern baptist
we are obviously way more serious now
contemplating marriage but we do not
live together because
his parents don't want us to and he has
not proposed to me yet despite saying if
i had a normal relationship with my
parents we would already be married
years ago basically i think he hasn't
proposed because he's scared of what his
parents will do or say i am basically at
my wit's end wanting the relationship to
progress and so does he but his parents
are in the are in the way what should we
do what should i do oh that's tough
because like you know what it sounds
like you're gonna end up like asking him
to choose between his parents and you
and like you never want to be that girl
i still can't get over the the news on
the family icloud even if his parents
weren't super religious like that's
horrible no matter what way you slice it
that's terrible but also like
the dad is that tech savvy to go through
the family icloud it also sounds like he
was a snoop no it sounds like it really
was like a terrible accident where like
nobody won very weird okay yeah moving
on from that piece what would you do
like you know
i let's say your parents [ __ ] hated
me
then you wouldn't be the person you are
though okay that's very sweet but like
no no no we need a real example no like
there's something going on there that's
like do you think there's something
wrong with this girl no i think that
there might be either something wrong
with this guy or he's using his parents
as an excuse to not commit that's a good
question like there's not
like if you love someone you convince
your family that
like unless the girls see them unless
the girl is a monster which she sounds
very lovely she's a toaster
so
obviously this can work but the guy is
using this as an excuse
yeah i actually think that's a good call
like
oh we would i would have proposed three
years ago but my dad like yeah nope not
true no and he's failed
he has failed to represent this girl in
a way that's meaningful to his parents
totally we're you know like we're all
responsible for managing communication
between your partner and and your
parents i'm sure you're so right i'm
sure he downplays it all the time
he's probably like oh yeah like we're
friends yeah
you got to meet these parents show them
that you're lovely right show up in a
nice if that's what you want like if you
want to impress them like show up in a
nice conservative dress
bring you know halal cookies like be
thoughtful but it seems like this guy's
not giving you the opportunity
it sounds like he is the one
that is stopping this from happening
it sounds like a conversation needs to
be had with him about
how he's talking about you to his
parents
and then telling him to man the [ __ ] up
right like how is he presenting this
relationship to his parents behind
closed doors yeah clearly not well i'm
just saying this is good advice that was
good advice he's totally he's the
problem he's a problem
all right first and third and final
sorry
thank you for reading my submission you
two had so much joy in my week i'm
getting married in a week and a few days
ago my dad let me know that he'd like
both him and my mom to walk me down the
aisle as is customary in the jewish
faith we are an interfaith couple my
fiance is catholic so we are weaving
jewish traditions throughout our day and
ceremony but we aren't being married by
a rabbi or having a traditional jewish
ceremony we're also getting married in
the south near my fiance's parents which
is a bit of which was a bit to my
parents dismay my mom and i are close
but also have a pretty tumultuous
relationship and have for most of my
teenage and adult life the idea of
walking down the aisle with my dad feels
so special and having my mom on my other
arm unfortunately just isn't what i
envision my mom doesn't seem to care
strongly about this but i don't want to
disappoint my dad especially because of
the no rabbi southern wedding thing do i
suck this up and make my dad happy or do
i figure out a way to tell them both
that i'd prefer to walk with dad only
many thanks toasters and a pickle it's
not a pickle your wedding day is not
about you your wedding day is about
everyone yeah that's what i was gonna
say well that's my that's my that's my
thought i i actually your parents raised
you it's a jewish wedding
for them
they're flying give them something
across the country put your mom on your
arm you won't remember it anyways so
here's what i have to say i don't agree
about the first thing you said like it's
literally about nobody but you and
anyone who makes it about themselves is
selfish i'm sorry then why then why
don't you just get married on a but
let me finish my thought but but
your parents are probably conceding a
lot in the sense that like you're not
having a jewish wedding and like for you
know jewish parents that's like
it's like the worst thing ever so like
i happen to really like there's so many
things i love about jewish traditions
and jewish weddings but i love that it's
not just the dad walking the bride down
the aisle first of all that's like so
old school like [ __ ] the patriarchy and
two it's like [ __ ] your mom also raised
you too arguably like your mom shoved
you out of her puss like moms do the
most moms are doing everything and then
like the dad gets to be like i'm giving
you away [ __ ] you're not hers to give
away like your mom [ __ ] does
everything that always pisses me off
about like traditional weddings and i
love that in
jewish weddings
it's the mom
and it's the dad for me it was just a
mom and i loved it so like i that
happens to be a tradition i really like
and value and i think it's like
it's a great equalizer so i'm all for
you doing this tradition also like
relationships with parents they're high
they're low but they're always your
parents and you never know where you
could be at your relationship with your
mom in 20 years and you'll always regret
you i don't think you'll really ever
regret having her do it but i do think
you will regret not having her do it
that's my piece i agreed
you were interrupting me you had
something you wanted to say no i was i
said the same exact thing as you except
in a different way no we said two
totally different things no we we're on
the same page no we were completely
different pages different chapters
different books we're on the same page
for sure for sure um so it is your
wedding day you can choose whatever you
want but i would
in insist that you just pause and think
about what we said because at the end of
the day you're allowed to make whatever
decision you want it is your day
but
i don't know
maybe we're biased because we're jewish
definitely but like
i think you should do it no we're biased
because we're parent-loving people
that's true too respect your damn mom i
know and even though she maybe makes it
hard sometimes she is your mom and as
jews it's one of our core
commandments respect honor thy mother
and thy father and sometimes they make
it hard but you have to do it you must
that's a good call too love bringing in
the commandments
that's our job cool love you peace
thank you guys so much listening to the
morning just a monday morning show where
we deliver the festive stories that you
need to know every monday friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please don't forget to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
bellows podcasting we're podcasting
foundation spotify institute republican
radio iridesce box all the places we're
listening podcasts find foreign
beautiful stunning it's where we are
hope you guys have an incredible amazing
stunning day and tomorrow's episode
watch out
see you then
you